من هم طالبان منذ توليهم
المسؤولية مرة أخرى ، كنا نطرح هذا
السؤال ، ما الذي سيفعله هذه
المرة بشكل جيد ، إليك بعض اللقطات الماضية
لمحادثاتي مع
الأفغان وواحدة من أولى
المقابلات الغربية مع مسؤول طالبان.
عندما استولوا على كابول لأول مرة
في عام
1996. الكثير من الناس في الخارج
يشاهدون الإجراءات التي اتخذتها طالبان ،
يريد الكثير من الناس معرفة ما
الذي ستفعله بشأن قضية المرأة وماذا عن
تعليم النساء تعليم الفتيات النساء
الأرامل العاملات  الذين ليس لديهم طريقة أخرى
لإعالة أنفسهم ،
أعلم أنه في وسائل الإعلام الغربية على وجه الخصوص ،
إنها دعاية ضد
حقيقة أننا ضد تعليم المرأة
وهذا ليس صحيحًا ، فهذا ليس صحيحًا
ولكن الفتيات لا يستطعن الذهاب إلى المدرسة لقد ذهبنا إل
المدارس  هنا كل شيء
مغلق ، يجلس مدير المدرسة في عزلة رائعة
يحتفظ بالكتب فقط في حالة تراجع
الطالبان ويسمح لتلاميذه بالعودة
مرة أخرى
ليس فقط إلى المدرسة ولكن جميع البرامج النسائية.
ave تم إيقاف
منظمات الإغاثة ، على سبيل المثال ، لم
يعد بإمكانها تعليم النساء أو الفتيات الصغيرات حول
الصرف الصحي للرعاية الصحية أو ألغام التوعية
بالألغام لا تزال مسؤولة عن معظم
وفيات المدنيين حتى أصغرهم يفهم أن
شيئًا ما ليس صحيحًا تشكو عزيزة البالغة من العمر عشر سنوات من
اضطرارها للبقاء في
المنزل طوال اليوم
نحن نقوم فقط بالأعمال المنزلية لتنظيف خبز
الخبز وكنس الأرضيات كما تقول
في جمعية أوكسفام الخيرية ، تجتمع مجموعة من
النساء المحترفات مرة أخرى
لأول مرة منذ أن طلبتهن طالبان
من ترك وظائفهن هنا قبل ستة أسابيع
لقد خرجوا لأنهم يريدون
العالم يعرف محنتهم أنا أحب عملي ،
إنه من حقي أن أعمل وأحتاج إلى
العمل
لأنني تلقيت التعليم في هذا البلد
وأنفقت الحكومة الكثير علي
وعلى عائلتي وأريد أن أعبر
عن نفسي لمجتمعي الذي أريد أن أخدمه  بالنسبة
لشعبي في بلدي ،
أخبرناهم للتو أنه في الوقت الحالي
لا ينبغي عليهم القدوم إلى المكتب في المدرسة ، لذا
حتى يحين الوقت الذي يمكننا فيه
الخروج بنوع من الحل  في أو
يمكننا توفير أماكن منفصلة لهم حتى
يتمكنوا من التعليم أو يمكنهم
العمل في المكاتب ، ماذا تقول عن
النساء
العاملات والذين يتعين عليهن العمل
لدعم أنفسهن بشأن هؤلاء النساء ،
لقد قررنا بالفعل
بعض هؤلاء النساء اللاتي يعملن  العمل في
المكاتب الحكومية أخبرناهم للتو
أنه حتى
الدرجة الثانية التالية
يجب أن يكونوا جالسين في
منزلهم وسيحصلون على أجرهم في منزلهم
يبدو مألوفًا منذ 25 عامًا وقد
انتهى الأمر ، وهذه هي عين محمد سانيك التي كانت في ذلك الوقت
نائب وزير الخارجية طالبان والذي
يترأس الآن مكتبهم السياسي في الدوحة
حيث يقول هو ورفاقه
نفس الأشياء ويقطعون الوعود نفسها.